yeah mr speaker i'm grateful for your
permission to make this statement
yesterday we began our day together you
i my right old friend the prime minister
and members from right across this house
when we broke bread together at the
parliamentary prayer breakfast
and we listened all of us to the words
of reverend les isaac who spoke about
the fact that responsibility that comes
with leadership
the responsibility to serve the
interests of others above your own
and to seek common ground of your party
your community and above all
your country
my colleagues will be forgiven for my
sense of deja vu
despite what it might seem
i am not one of life's quitters
i didn't quit when i was told that boys
like me don't do maths
i didn't quit when old school bankers
said i didn't have the right school ties
and i didn't quit
when people in my community said that i
should not marry the love of my life
i care deeply about public service
and giving back to this country that has
given me so much
that is why
when i got the call from my right over
friend the prime minister just over a
year ago i didn't hesitate to serve
again
it was a critical time for our country
tough decisions needed to be made about
when we were going to come out of
lockdown about supporting the national
health service and the care sector under
unprecedented stream
it has been an absolute privilege of my
life to have been trusted with these
responsibilities
and i can only hope
that my best has been good enough
it has undoubtedly also been one of the
toughest roles that i've had so far
the gravity of home office decisions
the scale of treasury decisions
but nothing matters more
than the health of your people of the
british people especially
and in the wake of a pandemic
caring for people's health and
well-being is truly a noble vocation and
so i would like to take this opportunity
to pay tribute to all of those across
the country working in health and care
sectors as well as those that i worked
so closely with in my old department
dhsc and in the nhs
there's so much that i planned for the
long term for the long-term reform of
our health and care systems and it is a
wrench to leave that important work
behind
now when i last gave a personal
statement from this seat
i spoke about the importance of
institutions and conventions
today it is about the importance of
integrity
and don't worry there's not gonna be a
series of these
institutions and integrity
are both central pillars that underpin
our great democracy
it doesn't matter what your political
perspective is
in this house i believe that we are all
motivated by the national interest
and that the public expects us all all
of us to maintain honesty and to
maintain integrity in whatever we do
this is not an abstract matter
we've seen in great democracies what
happens when divisions are entrenched
and not bridged
we cannot allow that to happen here we
must bring the country together as one
nation
effective governance inevitably requires
loyalty and collective responsibility of
course it does and i'm instinctively a
team player and i have completely
focused on governing effectively over
the last year
but treading the tightrope between
loyalty and integrity
has become impossible in recent months
and mr speaker i will never risk losing
my integrity
i also believe a team is as good as its
team captain
and that a captain is as good as his or
her team
so loyalty must go both ways
the events of recent months have made it
increasingly difficult to be in that
team
it's not fair
on ministerial colleagues to go out
every morning defending lines that don't
stand up and don't hold up it's not fair
on my parliamentary colleagues who bear
the brunt of constituents dismay in
their inboxes and on their doorsteps in
recent elections
and it's not fair
on conservative members and voters
who rightly expect better standards from
the party they supported
when the first stories of parties in
downing street emerged late last year
i was personally assured at the most
senior level
by my white olive friends then team
that and i quote
there had been no parties in downing
street and no rules were broken
so i gave the benefit of that
and i went on those media rounds to say
that i'd had those assurances
from the senior most senior level of the
prime minister's team
then we had more stories
we had the sue gray report
a new downing street team
i continued to give the benefit of the
doubt
and now this week again
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
and at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now
i welcome the prime minister's public
acknowledgement last night that matters
could have been handled better in who he
appointed and what was said about what
he knew when
and i appreciated his kind and humble
words and his humble spirit when i went
to see him yesterday and also the kind
letter that he has sent to me but i do
fear that the reset button can only work
so many times
there's only so many times
you can turn that machine on and off
before you realize that something is
fundamentally wrong
last month
i gave the benefit of doubt one last
time
but i haven't concluded
that the problem starts at the top
that is not going to change
i have concluded that the problem starts
at the top and i believe that is not
going to change and that's
means that it is for those of us in a
position who have responsibility to make
that change
i wish my cabinet colleagues well and i
i can see they have decided to remain in
the cabinet
they will have their own reasons
but it is
it is a
choice i know
just how difficult that choice is
but let's be clear
not doing something is an active
decision
i'm deeply concerned
about how the next generation will see
the conservative party on our current
course
our reputation
after 12 years in government
depends on regaining the public's trust
this is not just a personal matter the
philosophy and perception of
conservatives depends on it
it is central to the conservative ideal
that we believe in decency
in personal responsibility and in social
justice enabled by conventions and the
rule of law
the conservative mission to extend
freedom and prosperity and opportunity
is all at risk if we cannot uphold that
ideal yeah
and mr speaker it is not
only the the conservative party is not
the only great institution in need of
urgent repair
like everyone in this house i have been
dismayed by the drip grip of stories of
harassment and worse by members of this
house
so i'm also concerned about how the next
generation will see this house and the
health of our democracy
in recent years trust in our roles has
been undermined through a series of
scandals
but the one thing
we can control
is our own values and behaviors
so it is incumbent on all of us
to set high standards for ourselves
and to take action when they are not met
by others
mr speaker i'm grateful for the messages
of support that i've had from many
members of this house and beyond
i got into politics to do something
not to be somebody
so it is hard in one way but not in
another
being a good father
a husband a son and a citizen
is good enough for me
and if i can continue to contribute to
public life and my party from the back
benches
it will be a privilege to do so